the sports world and all of us here at
CBS are mourning the loss of a
well-known soccer journalist Grant Wall
the longtime Sports Illustrated writer
also a CBS Sports contributor died very
suddenly on Friday while covering the
World Cup in Qatar wall was married for
21 years to CBS News medical contributor
Dr Celine gounder in a statement Dr
gounder said this that she was in
complete shock but is thankful for the
support of her husband's soccer family
and many friends who have reached out
Errol Barnett looks at Wall's lasting
impact on the soccer World
the business of football is big now in
the United States but so is the actual
sport yeah we have pretty good teams now
he was one of the Premier advocates for
soccer in America tributes flowed in for
Grant Wall after his Unexpected death
over the weekend like many of you we
were distraught when we got the final
message this morning wall collapsed
suddenly in the Press Box at lucelle
stadium in Qatar while watching extra
time of Friday's quarterfinal matchup
between the Netherlands and Argentina I
was aware of some colleagues suddenly
across my left shouting for medical
assistance and it was obviously that
someone was in trouble Kier radnage a
British journalist working nearby says
war was treated for 20 to 30 minutes
before being taken out on a stretcher he
was then taken to a hospital in Doha but
doctors were unable to save his life the
Beloved writer may have gone into
cardiac arrest but no cause of death has
been released I think there is a great
sense of shock on Monday a wall wrote
that he had been feeling ill and that
his quote body had finally broken down
on him he said he had gone to a medical
center and doctors there told him he
quote probably had bronchitis everyone's
coughing here like so many journalists
have got a crazy cough he had just
turned 49 years old after a big win over
Iran the U.S faces the Netherlands on
Saturday wall was widely considered to
be the most well-known soccer journalist
in the United States he began covering
the beautiful game for Sports
Illustrated back in 1996 and became a
prominent advocate for the sport in the
U.S as it grew in popularity we're still
a growing Soccer Country in the United
States with I would say millions of more
soccer fans to be created wall was also
known as a face advocate for human
rights in soccer in Qatar he had
recently been detained for attempting to
enter a stadium while wearing a shirt
with a rainbow flag an active Defiance
against Cutter's lgbtq policies if I'm
being treated this way during the World
Cup when the attention of the world is
on Qatar and I'm an American who has a
pretty prominent media following imagine
how gay people in Qatar outside of World
Cups must feel or what they must endure
will continue to speak up for human
rights throughout the tournament I am
conflicted about this world cup but I'm
excited about
my favorite sporting event in the world
for CBS mornings I'm Errol Barnett